il est il est il est dans un truc tout
ce que je disais ouais cet été il est
venu chez moi il a exigé de manger du
caviar je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est
vrai ou pas c'est vrai je vous jure pas
vrai et ensuite il m'a regardé les yeux
livrets dans les yeux il a dit tu sais
Guillaume quand on est au sommet comme
moi après la saison que j'ai eu besoin
de faire je sais pas si je peux faire
mieux tu vois Michael Jackson quand il a
sorti thriller il y a plus rien sorti
après pendant des années ah ouais quand
même il en est là vous croyez mais même
des risques capillaires qui prenaient
pas avant ça c'est mon coiffeur qui est
revenu du Maroc non mais j'adore on
dirait que tu as une qui passe sur la
tête
dans trois semaines Mathieu qu'est-ce
que tu en penses la coiffure non de ce
qui vient de dire non la coiffure ça va
pas mon chou toi tu vas chez un coiffeur
faut que tu achète un visagiste
pas compliqué
les petits indépendants je vais passer
votre truc
c'est important de la coiffure quand
même mais oui un homme pas coiffé c'est
comme un lit parfait alors Gilles Verdez
je peux balancer sur Mathieu voilà ma
sœur
[Applaudissements]
remercie à 19h10 c'était les spectateurs
qui sont si nombreux à nous regarder
merci de retrouver la famille TPMP tous
les soirs vous êtes des amours et on
vous remercie
un vrai malaise en loge en agressant
littéralement Béatrice non et en lui
reprochant d'avoir piqué la place de
Valérie Benaim alors que là
alors que alors que la fauve Béatrice
n'y est pour rien et il a mis mal à
l'aise à tel point qu'elle est vraiment
mais offusqué
tu es un
menteurs
j'ai rien dit calme-toi quand même la
vérité j'ai appris un truc qui joue dans
un colombo
d'une autre époque en fait un gars c'est
qu'on voit qu'on a ressorti
une série j'adore vous aimez les trois
pièges les trois pièces
[Musique]
alors j'ai appris quelque chose tu te
retournes ici là j'ai appris et ça doit
être sur toi
indirectement sur sur ne t'inquiète pas
Mathieu rien je dirais pas tout ce que
je sais sur toi non plus
en fait
il est comme ça déjà en fait l'histoire
de Santorin non seulement il il a rien
dit mais tout est prémédité depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est à dire qu'il a
oui oui oui oui
ça fait des semaines qui nous montent
[Rires]
attention attention
mais bien sûr il a été il a été
totalement invité pour ce séjour et il a
mené l'image de l'émission pour se faire
inviter absolument
[Applaudissements]
on devait tourner à 9h30 et il pouvait
pas parce que ça touche pas quoi un truc
il y a un SMS de lui
je ne veux pas t'entendre
calme-toi il y a un SMS de lui qu'on va
pouvoir afficher je pense que la
production l'a reçu ou il dit qu'il ne
peut pas aujourd'hui en inventant un
rendez-vous avec une chaîne vous pensez
qu'une chaîne veut voir de leurs mots
peut-être lundi alors que vous aviez je
me dégoûte vous n'avez pas écrit ce sms
de leur mot si
[Applaudissements]